[Music]
Well, most movie music basically
only has two things to do: express the feelings of the characters or express the situation, so I do
n't want to do both,
so I really want to do both.  Fortunately, I've been doing this for the past 40 years, but
more than five years ago, I heard from
producer Toshio Suzuki, uh, I'd like to
hear from you again.  There
were no instructions at all, and I just wanted you to
watch it honestly without calling me anything like that, so I
wasn't even shown the screenplay at all, and even after I finished watching it, Mr.
Miyazaki didn't tell me anything else.  [
Music]
Hello, I still wonder how I should write a song every time I
take on a movie, and
for example, when I
write a new symphony, or even
when I write a symphony or a piece, I don't know at all.  I don't really
know where to start.Every time I start, I
start from scratch, and that has continued to this day.So
this time, when I
did Boi & Heron, I wanted to create something that was
n't that big orchestra that I had been doing for so long.  So
when I first saw the video, the first half was very much like that
lonely boy, or should I say,
depressed about his mother's death.  By
getting by with just the piano being
played, or with a few instruments added to it, I
think it brings out something like that boy's sense of loneliness.Then, the
second half becomes that slightly dark
fantasy, so let's move on from here.  I
was a minimalist at the beginning when it came to large formations, so
I went all out with a minimalist style, and this time I
played all the songs in a completely minimalist style.  Since I wrote a minimalist song that
took 40 years, I
was able to do what I wanted to do the most.Actually, Mr.
Miyazaki did
n't need that kind of music.In short, he didn't need that kind of music.  I
didn't want to treat it as special,
so I put music in. In other words, I did
n't want to treat the scene where Aoshita appears too special, so I
thought it looked a little unnatural.  I made a song and played it,
but Miyazaki-san
listened to it and said, Okay, maybe it's a bit exaggerated,
so I said, uh,
it was a certain kind of song,
but I kept playing it.
In the end, I said that that one was the best,
but in the next scene, it becomes 3 or 5, and then
in the next scene,
it becomes a proper song.  Mr.
Miyazaki was also really happy and said that it was a good thing to have this and that.I'm looking forward to it.What do you mean by
using the human voice?  I do
n't want to use it a lot, but I want to use it in an effective way, and in this
case, the existence of the character, that day, is
very important, and
although it doesn't appear that often, it is
also very important.  I thought it was a special part of the song,
so I took a look at it
here.I also used a chorus here, and it was also a female
chorus.
[Music] I
wrote that song called Akumi Why,
but I never thought that it would be the main theme of the movie, and I didn't even know if I would
use it in the movie.I knew that
Mr. Miyazaki was making a movie, and
my  I don't know if you'd say that, but I don't think
it's a birthday present. Actually,
on my birthday, I wrote music to use at the museum every year and brought
it with me. I was asked to do this for work, too.  It's
not that I was in charge of the music for Ghiblibis in the first place,
and I've been doing Mr. Miyazaki's work for
many years, so the song he brought to me for my birthday must have come from somewhere,
though I don't know the story.
I think I was writing a song that was in line with the movie based on the image I had in mind,
but the problem was that it was only after Mr. Miyazaki
came to my studio at that time that I wrote
that song.  The
moment I heard that, Mr. Miyazaki told the producer, Toshio Suzuki, that
this song
was the main theme,
so I didn't create it with that in mind.
I'm a
person who likes things like this, so once I think it's
good, I don't know whether I was really lucky or not.
[Music]
But it's better to keep the music at a distance from the images.
If you synchronize it too much with the images.
Well, I'm sorry, but like in Howe's movies these days,
it's mostly effect music, like
fast music when you run, and sad
music when you cry, because it ends up explaining a really great scene, and
I definitely don't want to do that.  I
think it's ideal to write music that doesn't explain the distancing screen, but instead encourages the viewer's imagination, which is
very important when it comes to movies.  I
think it's good to have something that people can imagine, and I do
n't want to try to explain the music too.There's nothing easy to write about, and
I'm afraid that I won't be able to write again.
When I suddenly think, ``I'm a genius, I'm a genius,'' and
that's all mixed together, and I think that's what gives me the power to say what I want to say
when I wake up in the morning.  No, I
don't have that song, but if I work hard to
create it, by the evening
a new song will be born in this world,
so it may be a long time
after various people have completed it.
It might be a song that people will listen to for a long time, or it
might end up just being played once more, but
I created something that doesn't exist in this world
[Music]
Because I can do it, that's why...  I really like composing music,
so no matter how many times I'm born again,
I want to be a composer.